- It's very complicated
with this body thing,
how it all happened.
I was painting as a young artist.
And mostly I was painting these clouds.
And one day, sitting and
painting and looking at the sky
I saw 12 military planes passing by.
And they made these incredible
drawings in the sky.
And I looked at them and I said,
"God, it's ridiculous. I'm
painting these paintings
that are so two dimensional.
Maybe I can go to the
military base and ask for
12 planes and then make all
the drawings in the sky".
I went to the military base,
and my father was general in the army.
So they call him and they say,
"Your daughter is in our base.
"Can you get her home because
she's out of her mind.
"She wants 12 military
planes to paint the sky.
"How much could this cost?"
So after that I stopped painting
and I start realizing that I can use
any material I want:
fire, water and the body.
At the moment when I start using the body
it was such enormous
satisfaction that I had,
and that I can communicate
with the public,
that I never could do anything else.
I could never go back to
the seclusion of the studio
and be protected by the space there.
The only way of expression is to perform.
And if I put the kind of hierarchy of art
I will always put definitely
the music on the top
because it's so immaterial.
And after this it will be performers.
And then any other art.
I mean, subject to point of view.